el ejército ruso continúa su ofensiva en
Ucrania a pesar de su salida de varias
ciudades que estuvieron a selladas desde
el inicio de la invasión las fuerzas del
kremlin anunciaron su ofensiva final
contra el estratégico puerto de mariupol
en la costa del martes esto como parte
de su nueva estrategia que se enfoca en
el este del país para lo que denominan
como la liberación del dumbas que está
ocurriendo con la estrategia militar
rusa Qué está pasando con esto pues lo
conversamos con nuestro primer invitado
del día él es Iván López miralles se
analista de política ROM especializado
en política exterior Gracias Iván por
estar con nosotros en este espacio de
Francia 24 directo América Cómo analizar
Entonces los nuevos objetivos militares
planteados por el kremlin que esperar en
los próximos días en el este de Ucrania
Muchas gracias Raúl hay que tener en
cuenta en primer lugar que los objetivos
del kremlin se fundamentaba en una
Guerra Relámpago para llegar aquí a
fijar coffe y poder capturar al gobierno
de voluminizan en base a ese pretexto el
ejército ruso se construyó en base a un
principio de defensa activa y no tanto
de ofensivas estratégicas terrestres a
este hecho si le sumamos el posible
cuestionamiento del liderazgo entre
suboficiales la capacidad de
proporcionar una logística eficiente a
esa gran capacidad mecanizada que es la
fuerza rusa o el posible cuestionamiento
o el fracaso de la vinculación entre
unidades terrestres y aéreas de forma
efectiva pues ha llevado a Rusia a una
revaluación de sus objetivos y hemos
visto como el Estado Mayor ruso pues va
a concentrar ese grueso de las
operaciones en el bombast donde ya hemos
visto que muchas de las unidades que se
se han reubicado seguramente hacia
Bielorrusia para el posterior despliegue
en la región del lombas y por lo tanto
estamos viendo como Rusia puede
concentrar sus esfuerzos en los límites
oficiales de los de dones y
van por qué digamos entonces si ese era
su objetivo principal las tropas rusas
intentaron llegar Pues digamos hasta la
capital hasta kiev hablemos también de
la importancia de maripo el nuevo
objetivo de las tropas rusas porque la
importancia de esta ciudad es
estratégica para llegar digamos a la
capital o al este de las regiones de
dionies y lugares
Mario Paul lo que tiene es también una
importancia simbólica puesto que ahí se
encuentra el grueso del Batallón azul no
que es esa vamos a decir a esa ideología
de lo que Rusia llama descensificación
no podemos pensar que en las
negociaciones de paz con Ucrania Rusia
podría decantarse solo con tomar Mario
Paul capitularla y por lo tanto cumplir
ese objetivo estratégico que partían
desde el principio no Además debemos
tener en cuenta que el mariposa también
forma parte ese o Blas no que de dones
que Rusia en principio ahora quiere
concentrar sus fuerzas y por lo tanto
veremos seguramente una gran ofensiva
gran escala en el este donde Rusia
concentrará Prácticamente todo el grueso
de su de su fuerza mecanizada y veremos
qué ocurre En las siguientes semanas se
puede quedar entonces las tropas rusas
solamente en esa región el don vaso
Podemos esperar que continúen en su
avanzada hacia hacia kiev además también
muchos analistas consideran que este
repliegue las tropas rusas se puede
considerar como una debilidad de las
tropas de del presidente Vladimir Putin
es cierto esto es una estrategia digamos
de engaños como también lo ha manejado a
lo largo de toda esta invasión para
luego ir hacia otra ciudad hacia otro
lugar y cumplir realmente su objetivo
que al fin al cabo nadie sabe digamos
finalmente cuál realmente es
sí uno de los principales problemas que
ha tenido Rusia durante el transcurso de
toda esta operación militar no es que
en toda esta expansión de terreno No si
tú quieres avanzar rápidamente Y eso es
lo que ha querido hacer Rusia desde un
primer momento avanzar rápidamente hacia
aquí
pues expones mucho lo que son tus
columnas militares no y por eso también
hemos visto que Rusia ha tenido muchas
bajas puesto que eres vulnerable a las
posibles emboscadas o a las fuerzas de
defensa
ucranianas no en base a ese pretexto lo
que podemos pensar es que Rusia puede
emprender una ofensiva por escalas no en
primer lugar Pues ahora va a concentrar
el grueso de sus operaciones en el
dombas a partir de ahí una vez que se
estabilice que mantenga sus puntos de
amortiguación en sumi porque recordamos
si pierde si llega a perder regiones
como sumis fronterizas con la federación
rusa podemos para pensar que Ucrania
puede llegar a llevar a cabo ataques no
en propio territorio ruso como ya
ocurrió en la región de bergoroth con
los helicópteros que guardaron a Baja
altura para burlar las defensas aéreas
rusas y atacaron depósitos de
combustible en territorio ruso esto
podría suceder muchas más veces si Rusia
no mantiene sus puntos de amortiguación
por tanto podemos pensar que en una
primera instancia Rusia va a mantener
sus defensas en la región del bambas va
a mantener a intentar integrar bien esa
zona para dos partes tener una posición
un poco de fuerza en las negociaciones
para intentar llegar a un acuerdo y por
otra pues poder llegar a una segunda o
tercera etapa donde pudiera llegar a
nuevas ofensivas y ya por último Quiero
preguntarle Iván qué pasa con Odessa Qué
ha pasado con esta ciudad que está
preparada desde hace muchísimo tiempo
para un inminente ataque de las tropas
rusas pero este ataque realmente nunca
ha ocurrido esta ciudad digamos que se
va a quedar
libre de cualquier ataque real de estas
tropas rusas o simplemente se puede
esperar en cualquier momento
yo creo que ahora mismo un ataque de
asalto anfibio no en Odessa está
prácticamente descartado ya hemos visto
como el ataque al puerto de everdiansk
donde
Ucrania no sabemos del todo cómo ha sido
el ataque si ha sido con drones va a
iraktar o con algún tipo de artillería o
con saboteadores pero han mermado
bastante la capacidad de asalta anfibio
de Rusia hemos visto por fuentes de
inteligencia abierta dos o tres buques
dañados por lo tanto ahora mismo
realizar un ataque a esa tan feos en
suicidio para Rusia era de sus
capacidades actuales por lo tanto si en
algún momento Rusia quiere llegar a
algún tipo de ofensiva de asalto anfibio
de esa será en el largo plazo pues vamos
a averiguar Qué pasa entonces en esta
guerra en Ucrania que continúa ya
estamos en 42 días de esta ofensiva
militar Gracias Iván por su tiempo por
estar con nosotros en directo América un
gran abrazo
Muchas gracias